okay okay what are your first thoughts I
mean well I the context I mean first of
all I'm thinking like is it and I'm
hoping then it's like a mental health
issue right that's my first hope
secondly you know what I see there
is his white supremacy right the things
that he said to him you're not a human
you know I mean this is stuff that we've
heard before to is then he uses religion
to then to that affirm what he's saying
he's hijacking now Christian exactly
yeah exactly and and you know it it's
it's really interesting just just just
watching that because I don't know what
what the context are those other people
Christian are they not Christian I don't
I don't know what that we don't know if
they're actual Muslim yeah exactly but
it doesn't seem like it's a Muslim it's
just a it's a black-white thing to me
that's what initially that's what I
that's what that's that's what I that's
what I think that's what I think and
that's what I see yeah yeah I start to
think my wheels start turning and I and
I think of Malcolm X when he wrote the
letter yeah and he said the truly I mean
without a doubt you know there's no
system out there that clearly you know
is so adamant about eliminating this
race problem like Islam yeah the
solution like he said yeah this is what
has me that goes through my mind ya know
it's interesting there's a pastor that
said the most segregated hour in in in
the country is church on Sundays you
know when services are happening because
every Koreans have their own churches
blacks have their own churches White's
have their own churches and so you know
this is something that I feel again like
it was interesting I saw something the
other day it said the it said the the
the the solution to fascism is education
and the solution to racism is travel hmm
right so I think that there's this idea
that if you're only around people like
you then yeah you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna you're going to think like
that so that's a beautiful thing like
when you go into our massage did I miss
everybody everybody call different all
different ways
nationality just in in in in Oakland it
was like a Burmese iftar a Vietnamese
iftar a Nigerian iftar a you know I mean
obviously there's the day sooner that it
happened I'm just saying there's like
four or five different ethnic groups
sponsoring an iftar inside of the must
[ __ ] right so now you know yeah it's
just it's just deep I mean I yes that I
don't know I mean I I am it's it's hard
even watching that it's kind of it makes
you feel uncomfortable yeah unlike oh
I'm uncomfortable about like but it
would bring this up because this is the
reality we're living in this is what's
really this is not one video they're
just popping up all over the place
yeah and you know a lot of times you see
this hypocrisy where people they'll
point out this fringe element you know
then same state and I'll try to make
Muslims look like you know yeah violent
and barbaric even though the data shows
and statistically this is there is a
professor Stanley fish I think his name
is he's right next to where we are as a
tuna he wrote an entire book on that are
Muslims more violent I think it was
called and then he flattened flattened
they argument I got it I got that
statistic of more Muslims less murder
that statistic over a hundred thousand
that's right per capita and it comes
down to like two points one percent
Muslim majority countries as opposed to
you know here you have it's like three
times more murder right so they flipped
us but now I'm seeing this is like the
this is like the the white and when I
say why I mean I'm white I'm Muslim it
doesn't matter you know give me Italian
polish whatever it is but people like
this lady's truly following the I think
of something that's connected to Jesus
where one came to Jesus said and it was
the gospel Matthew said oh good master
well the good thing can I do that I may
have eternal life and Jesus says why are
you calling me good there's none good
but God right and then he said if one
wants to enter to paradise Jenna you
know today he said one keeps the most
keep the commandments then he goes on he
said what are they said you know thou
shalt not commit adultery
Falls witness and the list goes on of
same thing that's in Islam but then he
said he said and love your neighbor like
you love yourself look at that so if
you're a true Christian and we want
people to be really prior if you're
gonna be a Christian be a true Christian
right and because this is not a true
Christian right so this mute true human
beat you so this is like that white all
right this is the white Christian Isis
that were yes Garrett you're starting to
see more of this come come up yeah yeah
you know it's it's really interesting
it's really like you said I'm not I'm
not
like I said uncomfortable in that the
term that's being thrown around all the
way now I'm uncomfortable no I like like
first of all I'm thinking like you know
how's my man gonna respond you know and
he's responding like a Christian he's on
some like turned the other cheek
he's doing it he's doing it so it's
really interesting here you're seeing
that he's claiming and he's acting yeah
so we can make all the claims that we
want live it man yeah live it have you
have you have you seen because I mean
the data shows you have Islamophobia is
like you know now these Dave again with
the with the amount of attacks now on
mush kids on Muslims you know it's like
5% 500% increase I think just recently
they had an article of how many Muslims
have been attacked and that how are you
guys there in California and Tabarrok
law from the grace and mercy of Allah we
we haven't experienced that you know I
think there's this kind of live and let
live and tolerate you kind of leftist
Berkeley progressive and that's where we
that's where we are you know and and I
think you know well I just say you know
how many lovely you know there have
there were some some instances on campus
you know didn't mean but again it sounds
like me and I'm trying to write them off
but it did something they were kind of
some mental health issues but I mean
definitely there are you know obviously
you had this mile mile oh yeah innopolis
who was you know fighting to come to
campus and talk his talk big yeah yeah
that whole Breitbart crew you know and
and you know so you actually had that
but again you know I see this as I see
these guys as opportunists to be honest
with you yeah it's just a new way to
make my own
Pam Geller is making you know what is it
a hundred and twenty thousand off of a
blog or something like this big business
big businessmen and it's and for those
who apostate from Islam it's big
business man yeah you know and and and
and everything tanks looking to grab you
up and long as you've got the story that
I were and then and then come to find
out what are their families say dude was
never in Hamas dude demeanor he didn't
even pray he was like a secular Muslim
who had no connection to Jesus this
leach a lot or something like that
whatever his name is I know you can
Google one of these guys that that pop
up and then take him as if he had he's
advising Ray Kelly like the New York you
know Police Commissioner and these types
of things when you dig and do your due
diligence on these individuals that's
the scary thing that they don't bring in
someone like you they don't bring in
someone like you know a representative
from you know the the Muslim community a
scholar or someone who is gonna come in
and teach law enforcement they they have
some of these they've this is a scary
thing and many of the law enforcement
agencies they have a lot of these
Islamophobes
teaching their classes yeah that's very
yeah yeah exactly and I think and I
think so at that point then you're not
looking for a solution yeah getting I
mean and and because then you've put in
everyone's in the minds of these cadets
or whoever they are that that everyone
that that that everyone's a potential
threat yes everyone's a potential threat
who's a Muslim and it was really
interesting I was I was I was looking
the other day I was reading something on
the plane the other day and it was
talking about how even just the West has
shifted in its in its kind of you know
the hijab was kind of like this like the
idea of the harem and it was exotic and
they sexualized it and that's how it was
kind of portrayed now it's like you know
what I mean this it's it's it's a it's
seen as like leaning towards violence
and anyway he jumped that yeah that
would put because a woman because of
this whole idea about conviction yeah as
you become more religious right
religiosity Bri it brings you to this
place of violence and I'm like no that's
so insane that's insane
I can bring
like I said I've lived about 10 years in
the Middle East my experience has been
complete opposite of that and that's
just that's traveling through the Middle
East not just in one country one group
of people yeah but I see that that's a
lack of knowledge of like this mad
person a little bit of knowledge of
Christianity that's right and now what
happens right that's right he's becomes
a zealot he becomes a fanatic and
extremists made a little bit of
knowledge of Islam right but probably
more turn into extremists with you know
all of the violence that's happening in
his in our own country but more Islam
helps to humble you to become a better
human being the best version of yourself
that you were saying a hundred percent
and I mean that's the whole thing to
this whole argument about you know
killing the non-muslims in both I mean
what I'm gonna take Shahada and like go
kill my family right from like like
that's my duty now as a Muslim it was
just insane like that you it's insane
that you'd actually believe that but
that's the that's exactly what it's it's
insane that you would actually believe
that